we are here with jessica biel and
melanie linski who starr in the new hula
series candy it is so epic okay now
before you go if you don't mind will you
play my favorite game with me um some
rapid fire questions for both of you
absolutely yes all right it's time for
the final five
[Applause]
all right
melanie i'm starting with you and then
jessica you're gonna answer as well okay
melanie who was the last person you
creeped on social media
oh my god
honestly probably celeste baba do you
know celeste barber i love her she's the
greatest comedian she's australian and
she's going on tour i love her
oh she's so funny good one to creep
jessica
cooking with fiona with pasta with fiona
something this incredible cook that
makes these insane
pastas with vegetables that look like
art i've never seen anything like this
in my life it's unbelievable when i was
like maybe i'll get my kids to eat this
because it looks so insane okay i'm
already going to do a list on the
show website drewberrymarshow.com i'm
going to put all these recommendations
celeste barber pasta with fiona fiona
okay um melanie uh
is there a bad habit you have nobody
knows about
uh i guess reading the comments
oh
yeah honestly i like it it is a bad one
uh jessica same with you bad habit
um
i
i eat
and drink coffee in the shower and the
tub and my husband can't stand it
that is interesting because i feel like
that is the one place my appetite is
curved
i'm just trying to do so many things at
once so quickly oh god i just love it so
much though don't open up pandora's box
for me this is the only this is the only
safe zone okay melanie top song on your
phone right now on repeat oh gosh my my
daughter still
just only wants to listen to gwen
stefani's version of jingle bells
i love that
why wouldn't she
song right now that you love
the song that i love well
i can't stop listening to groove theory
tell me i mean that's what i listen to
all the time in the car by myself
melanie first celebrity crush
my first celebrity crush was oliver
platt
oh interesting
it's my like all time yeah like and
current celebrity crushes would be dave
grohl and gail simmons from top
oh my god i'm so hot for gail simmons
too oh god yes there's never been anyone
sick she's the most beautiful face like
unique features okay jessica first
celebrity crush
i mean
that was such an interesting answer mel
i mine was mine's probably you know
jonathan taylor thomas like gold school
jtt
[Applause]
bop magazine 16 i love it bringing me
back yeah
you guys i love you both so much
in life in your art as humans as women
as mothers as
women who are trying to do it all and
keeping it super real about it i just
appreciate you endlessly you can catch
jessica biel and melanie linsky in the
finale of candy airing on hulu tonight
um it's one of the best shows i've seen
and as long as i can remember you guys
are so good in it thank you so much for
putting this out there in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you